Clay,
Joey telling shit stories for sure.
And he told us about when he shit,
uh,
in his backyard and somebody thought it was a bear.
She will let her dogs out every day until
I took a shit and I put my back against the wall.
When you shit outside,
it's not going to be a decent shit.
It's going to be like explosive.
So when I got up,
but it looks like somebody got shot in the head,
they,
we shut off behind me.
So she's sitting there with French poodles,
Chihuahuas and she's looking at the wall like what the fuck happened?
Then all of a sudden she actually walks up close to it squints and looks and
looks around and runs in the house.
I'm watching all this,
I can't breathe.
And now I go into the computer cause my wife's very decent.
I'm sitting there for half and then my wife comes in,
she goes,
where are you home all day today?
I go,
yeah,
why?
She goes,
I just had a conversation with Susan.
She wanted to know if you heard anything in the backyard.
I want to get Sushi,
but give it a go get Sushi.
I eat a lot of it.
The rice pushes everything.
I had plans to go get it.
A weed store.
You want to go to post office.
But I made a detour.
I plan to go home,
but I left the house key in the house so I had to climb around the window.
That's what happened.
Yeah.
When I pulled myself up,
I actually landed with my stomach on the window and that you really made it push
it out more like,
and I sign it and fuck and my hands are struggling in the window
and the cat's scratching at me.
Right.
And I might get you,
me your fuck.
Sorry.
Ran Out.
Ran down the stairs.
Oh shit outside.